[音楽]まあこれから
まあ受験というか試験というか
まあそれで人間の能力
まあそちらの関係についてお話をさせていただきます
普通の学校に受験を受験する方々はあまり少ないので
まあそこら辺にそんなに合わせたっても
受験が終わっている方々には意味がないかもしれません
で まあ世俗的なまあ 受験についてはまあいろんなことを言えることは言えますけどね
いろいろ方法はあるんですが
まあ関係ない人の前で言っちゃうとね
あんまり良くないんですよ
確実に受験する人に言ってあげないと
ですから 一般的なところを考えてみようとします
試験というのは まあ一つ
自分のことをまあ測ってみるということになるんですね
私たちは何か受験するということは
まあ他人に評価してもらうということになるんですね
そこでまあ他人がね この試験をする側が何か尺度を持ってないと
これで人を測ってみようと
で 持ってないと自分を測れないんですよ
ですから まあ試験というそのものの意味はね
他人が関係ない 関係ないわけじゃなくて
他の他人が何か自分勝手な尺度を持っていて
それで自分の能力やら何やらまあ測ってみることになるんです
で それででも自分の自由っていうのはなくなるんですよ
私はこういうものだからということは
もうちょっと成り立たないんですね
あなたは何者であるか私が決めますよと言って
自分の尺度で測ってみることなんですね
ですから この受験する人々は
まず一生我々は試験にさらされていますからね
人生は死ぬまで で 学校の試験だけ試験ではないんです
人生 ずっともう試験なんですよ
ですから その場合は まあ人が自分のことをまあ評価する
測ってみるということになっているんだと
で 尺度が他人が持ってるんだと
だからなかなか人生は自分の自由で
自分の思考ではいかないということをまず考えておかないと
いわゆるこの世の中で生きている間は
なかなか自由で 自分の意見で
思考で 自分の思う通りにはいかない
とにかく誰かが何か言うんです
これは違いますよと こういう風にしなさいよとかね
こういう風に喋りなさいよと
こういう風に歩きなさいよと
もう何でも言われるんです
で それに合わせないと
なかなかこの人間の世界で生きていられないんですね
ですから まあ私は自由だとか何とかとか
まあいい加減なことを言ったっても
実際はもう生まれた時から死ぬまで自由にはなれないんですね
いつでも騙されるという
もう評価される ということにはなっています
だからこの世の中で成功する人っていうのは
まあまあ それにちゃんと準備しておくんですよ
だから自分の自由うんぬんではなくて
まあいつでもみんな好き勝手に評価するんだからね
判断するんだから ということで
まあどういうふうに判断しても
まあ自分が合格点を 取っ
られるように一生努力すれば
死ぬまでどこにも失敗はないと思いますよ
ですから まず考えてほしいのは
そのポイントなんですよ
人生そのものが子どもたちだけではなくて
みんなもう受験しているんだと
毎日何か試験あるんだと
人に会うたびに相手が自分のことをもう測ろうとする
ですから その場合は悪い点数を出さないようにと
この人間関係まずくなったとかね
というのはそういうことなんですよ
うまくいかなかったとかね
失敗しましたとか その人間関係というのは
結局はこの優しく 我々は互いにコミュニケーションをとっているわけじゃないんです
結局 相手をもう何て言いますか
試してみようとかに測ってみようとということになるんです
ずっと心にあるんですよ
お話しするときでも 判断
判断 判断ばっかりしているんですね
そこで自分が相手からいい点数取れなかったら
もうすごいもう人間関係まずかったとということになるんです
結局 人間関係っていうのは試験関係なんですね
それを忘れちゃうとみんな失敗します
夫婦関係でも 姑と嫁さんの関係でも
親子関係でも 結局互いに測ってます
子どもは親を測っているし
親が子どもを測っているし
そこでいい点数取らなかった人がもう大変な目にあっちゃうしね
子どもに親がいじめられる時でも
子どもが自分の試験に親が合格しなかったということでいじめるんです
親が子どもをいじめる時でも同じことです
だから この世の中で平和に生きたければ
成功しながら生きたければ
合格しながら生きたければ
まあ一生試験やと一人一人の試験
人間が試験を出してるんだと
私は受験者やと 一生と思って生きていれば
まあ何のことなくすごく気楽に生きていられるんだと思います
そこにこの屁理屈 屁理屈ってわけじゃないんだけど
人間自由ではないかと
自分のアイデンティティを持って生きていればいいんじゃないかとかね
といっても あんなものはみんなよく言われるでしょ
マスコミとかなんとかところしか私は情報を得られませんだから
あの まあ現代の人々はちゃんとした自分のアイデンティティを持って
自分の意見をちゃんと持って生活するべきですよとかいう時は言うんだけど
もし自分の意見を出したところでえらく叩かれるんですよ
自分の意見を言ったところで
自分のアイデンティティ
個性を持って生きてみようと思ったら
もう親に叩かれるわ 社会に叩かれるわ
学校の先生に言われるわとかね
会社から何か言われるとか
もう切りがないんですよ
だから結局何言ってるんですかと
人は自由だって言ったんではないかと
人は自分の個性を持って
アイデンティティを持って生きていればいいと言ったんではないかといっても
もうこれはその時効かないんですよ
だから私が言うに これ
人間言うことをあまり当てにしない方がいいんですよ
誰も真剣に喋っているわけじゃないんです
自分でも何喋ってるか分かってないんです
ただ あの...ただ喋ってるだけ
うるさいだけなんですよ
結局は で 私は思う 例えばね
時々ありますね このシート張ってる
あの家とは言わないね
まあこういう建物とか作ったりね
普通この倉庫とかそういうものを作る場合
天井とか何もないんだからね
あの 鉄じゃなくて あの
何て言いますか アルミのシート入ってあって
それに雨が降るとどうなるんですかね
すごいうるさいんでしょ
中もいられないんです
そんなもんですよ 世界は
喋るは喋るは喋るは もうえらいことを言うんですよ
説教するわ こうしなさい
ああしなさいと言う まあ結局誰もそんな真剣でもないし
物事分かってもないんです
ですから この個性ということを考えたっても
結局は個性を認めない
それなんでだ？それだったら人間っていうのは個人差とかアイデンティティとか個性とか持って生活しなくちゃいけないんでしょうやと
偉そうに大きい声で言うんですかね
それは何か自分が損しているんですよ
何か人から自分にはアイデアが出てこない
それで人からそれアイデアやら新しいアイデアやら出して欲しがるんですね
それが出てこないと やっぱり個性を持たなくちゃいけないんだと言うんですよ
結局わがままなんですよ
出したところでものすごく綺麗さっぱり否定されるんですよ
で まあそういう世界で我々生きてるんですね
ですから この我々 私たちは結局個性を出すか
アイデンティティを持つかとかね
そういうところはまああの悪いことは私は思ってないんですよし
私はできるだけ人の個性は徹底的に認めますけど
私は一人だけいないんだからね
この世の中で人間っていうのは別々でね
それは世界はどう思うか
自分では分かりませんし
責任も持てないし たとえ私が個性を持っていますよと
個性があったって一言文句言わないんだよと言って
それに乗ってしまって
世界で自分のわがままで生きていれば
どういう結果になるかまた分からなくなっちゃうんです
まあそういうことですよ
人間関係っていうのは
ですから この我々はもう自分なりのいい加減な論理で人間でいいのではないかとかね
自分の好きなことをやればいいんじゃないかと思っても
世界はいつでも私たちを試してるんです
試す場合は必ずしも尺度というものがあるんです
それで試すんです そこで問題は
我々はもう試験を受けるとします
人に測れてもらって いい点数出そうではないかと
あの人に評価してもらおうと
学校に評価してもらおうと
大学から評価してもらおうとか
いろいろ試験に合わせるんでしょ
ということは 私たちは相手の尺度に自分を合わせることになるんです
あるいはこの会社に英語を達者でなきゃ入れませんと言ったら
入社する人々はもう英語を勉強するでしょうに
勉強して英語も喋られる人間になるんでしょう
ですから 受験するということは
自分の人格が変わるということなんです
それはよく覚えてほしいんです
だから一生受験受験するし
受験するたびに自分の人格が変わるんです
相手に合わせちゃいますからね
それも大変大事な注意ポイントなんです
無視できるものじゃないんです
それで出てくるのはどんな受験も受ける必要あるかっていうことなんです
例えば とんでもない尺度を持っている場合は
自分の人格もとんでもないことになってしまっちゃいますよ
例えば暴力 暴力団に入りたくなると
そちらの尺度はあるんですよ
受験があります 誰でも入れてくれるわけじゃないんです
暴走族に入りたくなったら
そちらにもちゃんと試験があるんです
いろいろ調べるんです
そこでもし暴走族に入れてくれたならば
もう自分の人格はそちらの人格になってるんです
暴力団に入れてくれたならば
入団認めたならば もう自分の人格も暴力的な人にもなっているんです
でなきゃ合格できません
ですから 我々は死ぬまで人に試されていますが
みんなに認めなくてもいいんです
必ず なんて落第と言うんですか
必ず落第するべき試験もあります
合格したらダメだよと
どんな試験も合格する必要ないんです
まあこういう試験だったら堂々と落第するぞと
という試験もこの世の中にはあります
それは尺度の問題なんですね
相手が危険な尺度をとんでもない尺度を持ってるんだったら
もうその試験は受けない方がいいんです
例えば 学校の中で 勉強中でも
みんな仲間 グループ作っちゃうんですね
そのそのグループに そのグループの試験合格しないと入れてくれないんですよ
そこでとにかく学校で仲間を作らなくちゃあかんやという人の話に乗せられて
もうわざわざ何かにグループに入る必要って
それは考えた方がいいんですよ
そのグループがどんな尺度を持ってるかと
とんでもないろくでもない尺度で
そのグループは受験するんだったら
まあ一人でいればいいんです
その場合は 学校の人生は友達がなくても
悪い仲間がなくてもいいんです
そういうふうに その場合は仲間外れになっているんだとかね
友達がないとかね やっぱりこの人の学校の人生は落第やとか言うかもしれません
それで落第していいんです
その場合は で そういうことを尺度について
尺度について覚えてほしいポイントですね
それから 尺度がいい尺度であるならば
まあ問題ないんです 例えば学校の試験というのは
まあ知識を測るんですね
だから知識尺度なんですよ
だから学校の試験は合格すればするほど
自分が知識人になってるんです
よく知識のある よく勉強を覚えている人間になるんですね
だから数学の試験を合格したら
もう数学できる人に人として認められる
そういうふうに この大学までだいたい知識を測るんですね
学校という世界はもう単純に知識だけ測る世界ですから
まあそれは合格した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
合格するんだったら まあ一番もう上のレベルでAクラスで合格した方がいいんです
で それにちょっと苦労したってもね
どうったことはないんです
なぜならば もう学校で自分の人格をわかるわけないよとか
あの先生は数学しかわからんではないかとか
あの先生は音楽しかわからんではないかとかね
そんなことはどうでもいいんですよ
音楽しか教えていない先生は音楽の試験をする
それで自分の音楽能力のみを測るんです
数学の先生は数学能力のみを測るんです
だから私たちはそんなに嫌になる必要ないんです
その先生にわからないとかわからなくてもいいんです
自分の人格をすべて測っているわけじゃないんです
ですから 決して学校の世界ではね
教育の世界ではあらゆる試験があるんですけど
測るのは自分の能力のほんのわずか一部なんですよ
そこで私と話し合った人々の中でも
大体落第した人々が何人かいて
私はそれは本当は嫌なんですね
あまり学問 知識なんかはもうあまり評価しないんだけど
で やっぱり誰でも試験は落第して欲しくないんですね
情けないと思いますよ
で その場合 よく聞いてみると
自分が単純に試験を受けるんじゃなくて
偉そうな余計なことまで考えちゃうんですね
そんな余計なこと考えたって
向こうにとっては関係ないんですよ
例えば 法律の受験をすると
弁護士になるためやと思って
まあこれでも法律っていうのはあんまり良くないとか
いい加減やとかね それで人を助けられるんでしょうかとかね
あれやけど そんなことはどうでもいいんです
ただ 試験を作る側が法律的なノウハウ
テクニックを持っているかないか
ただそれだけ見るんですから
自分がそのテクニック身についているんだよと
それだけ言えばいいんです
踊りのダンスの受験だったら
まあ踊ってあげればそれで終わるんですよ
ダンスっていうのはもうあまりもういいことではないんだぞとかね
あれやこれやとか言ったっても
そちらにはもう関係ないんです
ですから 試験する側があくまでも硬い尺度を持ってます
それは変えれ変えてくれない
それに合わせて受験する
で そういうふうに決めておいた方が
だから試験で自分の全部能力を測るわけじゃないんだと
例えば 数学のプロみたいに能力ある人が英語の試験を受けると
そこでも落第すると その人はすごく怒る
私はこれほど頭がいいのに
この人々にわからないんですかと
わからないんですよ そちらは英語の試験しているんだから
だから数学の教授であろうか
普通のTOEFLの試験を受けたところで
もう負けたとせちゃうと TOEFL
試験した側から見れば
この人はバカで英語がわからないんだと
数学の教授ということは関係ないんです
ですから 自分の人格はもう問わないんですよ
試験の場合は 自分が何者かと
試験を受ける場合は それをまず覚えておく
そうすると 子供にでも気楽にどんな受験でもすることはできるんですね
これはもう自分のすべての生き方を測ることじゃないんだと
この試験さえやっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
この試験にはこういうこういう内容
こういう科目聞くんだから
そこら辺ちょっと勉強して覚えておけばいいんじゃないかと
そうやって気楽に向こうの尺度に合わせるんですね
そこで知識試験 受験 いわゆる学校の試験ですよ
それは仏教でも若い時はやりなさいと
頭が悪くてどうにもならんやと
と言っているんです お釈迦様は
子供のときやることもないでしょうに
もう親がもう食べさせてくれるわ
服も洗ってくれるわ 悩むこと何もないでしょうに
それで遊びだけだったら
ものすごい人生つまらないんですよ
自分もちゃんとした仕事をしないと
そうするとちゃんと仕事をしているんだよということで
プライドを持って生きていられるんですよ
食って遊んで寝るだけだったら
ものすごく惨めで 親にバカにされて
自分の家なのに 自分の親なのに
もう人格がなくなっちゃうんですよ
ですから ブッダもお釈迦様もおっしゃるのは
子供の頃はもうバリバリと勉強しなさいよと
そうするともう親と同格になるんです
父親が私は仕事をして
ちゃんとあなた方を食わしているのではないかと威張ったって
私もちゃんと勉強して頑張っているのではないかと
お互い様やと 母親にもそれも同じことを言えるんです
そうするとすごい自分
それで人格が守られるんですよ
一人前の人間として たとえ子供であろうとも
ですから まあ子供たちの場合は
ちゃんと知識を獲得しなさいというのは
仏教でははっきりと言っているところなんですね
知識を得る場合もいろいろ裏技があるんですよ
それで学問的な裏技はみんなもうむちゃくちゃ知っていると思いますけど
みんな忘れている 裏技が一番大事なことはあるんですよ
いつでも我々は人間と一緒に生活しているんですよ
先生も人間なんですね
教えてもらう学生も人間なんですよ
だから この人間と人間の間の関係ね
お互いに優しく 楽しく付き合うことが大事なんです
先生はサラリーマンやと思っちゃうと
もう勉強できないんです
その教えてくれる先生とはものすごくこの仲良くする
友達になってみる そうやって教える側の愛情をなんとか買わないと
先生から見れば もう自分の生徒が可愛くて放っておけないと
心配すると本気で そういう感情を作らないと
生徒たちが 勉強は苦しくなるんですよ
だから先生から見れば
生徒たちは何か自分の弟たち妹たちみたいな感じ
あるいは年上の先生だったら
なんか自分の子供ではないかとと思うと
ものすごく愛情というものを教える側に生まれてくるんですね
それでものすごい簡単にこの知識の伝達が行うんです
その場合は 先生の授業はものすごくわかるんですよ
先生をわかっているならば
授業もわかるんです 授業だけ聞こうと思っても
これも普通の人間には無理
生まれつきものすごい脳細胞が働いている人だったら別ですけど
普通は無理です ですから
自分がそれほど頭が良くないと思うならば
先生を友達に回すしかないんです
友達に回しちゃえば 頭悪いと思っていた自分の頭も何のことなく良くなるんです
それはすごい大事な裏技なんです
学校は嫌とかね 学校に行きたくないやとかね
そういう問題 全部解決します
だから自分と一緒にいる仲間よりも
なんとかして先生たちの機嫌を取るようにした方が
どんな噂立ってもいいんです
まあ子供がやっていることだからね
あいつはずるがすごいかなとか思われたって
それはそんなに関係ないしね
大人は子供に対しては親切でしょうし
ですから まあ 自分を何て言いますか
売るんですよ 人気を買うんです
先生たちの人気者になる
それしたらもう学校も面白いし
勉強もものすごく簡単に進むんです
そこで世の中でこの勉強
あの人は頭がいい この人は頭が悪い
あの人は勉強できるとか
そんな大したことないんですよ
この世の中での学校で教えるものっていうのは
あまりにも単純で どんな人間にも理解できるんです
脳に病気がない限り 時々脳にいろんなね
病気が その人は学校に行かないんだから
特別な施設なんかで育てられますからね
脳に特別な異常な病気がない限りは
この教える勉強っていうのはね
何のこともない できない
できるんですよ バカに感じるほど単純です
数学も工学も科学も もう何でも
歴史も社会学も国語も
ちょっと調べてみてください
なんてバカバカらしい
単純ではないかと 私は子供の頃
勉強してあ まいったということは一つもなかったんです
これができっこはないとかね
なんだ こんなもんかという感じでしたけどね
ですから 実際に教育の内容に入ってみると
ものすごい単純なもので
だから勉強できないということは
もう私から見ればありえないことなんです
それだけありえないこと
そちらにあるのは別な問題なんですよ
自分がこの乗り物に乗ってない
バスに乗ってないと もうしょうがないでしょうに
バス停に待ったままでいるんだから
乗らなかった自分が悪いだけで
乗ってしまえばバスが運んでくれるんですよ
だから教育という乗り物に乗ってみると
それはもう簡単な方法で
もうやっぱりまず先生たちと仲良くする
お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
もう現代言葉で言えば仲良くするだけで十分ですけどね
友達にするとかいうことは十分ですけど
お釈迦様はかなり尊敬しなさいと
親と同じく 親と同じレベルで見てみれば
親よりもたくさんのことを教えてくれますよ
先生たちは 親にはできないんだから
教育は だから親よりもすごいことをやってくれますよ
例えば 親が普通のサラリーマンで
自分の子供は医学部に入ったとします
それで医者にしてくれるでしょうね
親にはまるっきりできないんだから
だからみんなこの先生たちというのはすごいことをやってくれるんだと
自分がこの社会で一人前にしてくれるのは
まあ結局は先生なんですよ
だからそれぐらい大事な人物なんです
その人を敵に回して幸福になると思いますかね
敵に回して喧嘩して バカもいいところなんですね
だからお釈迦様はちゃんと先生を敬いなさいと
尊敬しなさいと それはすごい厳しいですよ
インド文化では 先生といえばものすごい厳しい
厳しいっていうのは この関係がものすごい尊敬する
いつでも言うことを聞く
従うというふうな インド文化ではすごい厳しく習慣があって
今もインドの世界ではね
先生を尊敬する生徒たちがみんな頭がいいんです
世界一流になるんです
今もね 世界でソフトウェアの開発はもうほとんどインド人半分ぐらいやってるんだから
まだ中国人も入ってますけど
全部商売してるのは西洋人ですけど
でも結局はコードを全部作って
そのそのきめ細かいところは全部もうそこら辺どこら辺インドでもやったりしてね
マイクロソフト会社にやら
他の会社にやらもうバンバン売っているでしょうし
それもかなりの知識能力は必要な世界でしょうし
やっぱり調べてみると
結構まあ先生たちを尊敬するんですよ
みんな そういうことで頭がよくなっちゃうんです
ですから 勉強っていうものはそんなに難しいことではありません
すごいバカバカらしいほど簡単なものなんです
でも 学生がそれをすごく難しく感じる
それはもうやっぱりもうちゃんと乗ってない
乗り物に オートバイに乗ったっても
いい加減乗っちゃうと
もうどうなるんですかね
オートバイで考えた方がいいんですよ
ちゃんとオートバイに乗っている
前に乗っているのは先生で
彼が免許証を持っていて
自分が後ろに乗る それで立ったり
あっち見たり足を上げたりしちゃうと
突然ブレーキでもかけちゃうと
急にカーブをとっちゃうと
この人はもうそちら落っこちてくるんだから
だから落第っていうことは成り立つんです
ですから まあ一旦オートバイに乗ったら
じっと握っておけば その運転する人
決して落ちません 捕まっておけば
だから 仏教から言える勉強の裏技はそれなんです
それは教えてくれないでしょ
世界では 愛情がない世界だからね
憎しみと競争と嫉妬ばっかりでしょうに
だからもっと優しく もっと楽しく
みんなと仲良く 先生の家に強引に行ってご飯を食べて帰ったりとかね
そういうぐらい関係を持たないと
親と喧嘩したら もう勝手に先生の家に行って
今日はこちらで泊まりますからと
なんで親と喧嘩したんだから
それぐらい人間関係を作っておいた方がものすごい勉強できる
そんな無理じゃないでしょうに
結局は 先生から見ても自分気に入っている生徒だったら
もう勝手に来たっても先生何も気にしないし
で 日本ではね 先生たちももう人間ができなくて
ろくでもない人間 人物がいっぱいいるんですけど
やっぱりそれも途中で起こることなんですよ
最初に若い時 学生 先生になる時は
そんな悪いことをする気持ちは全くないんですよ
みんな真剣に受験して
生徒 学生 教師としての免許を取ってますよ
そこで一旦教えている途中で人間関係はないわ
生徒たちにいじめられるわ
あらゆることができて
もう本人も人間できてないんだから
どんどん悪い方向へ走っちゃうんですね
ですから まあ簡単に今の先生っていうのは信じられませんとかね
信頼できませんとかって言っても
結局みんなずっとそういう風にやったんだから
そうなってるんですよ
親も先生に対して親切ではありませんし
文句ばっかり言うだけで全然理解しない
自分が一人二人だけの子どもの面倒を見られないくせに
30人 40人の面倒を見る人に言いたい放題文句を言う
先生たちにももう芯がないんだから
出て行けとは言えないんですね
堂々と言えばいいのに
あんたに子ども何人いるんですかと
それは管理できないでしょうにと
その年のみんな集めてこちらでいるんだからね
だから口出すなよと どう育てるかはこちらで考えるんだよ
こちらはプロだからというぐらい言えばいいのに
態度取れないんですよ
私も一時教師やっていたんだからね
誰にもめげなかったんです
愚痴出すなよと 出て行けと
それでおびえて出て行くんです
二度と口を出すをしない
なぜならば 自分がちゃんと仕事をしているんだという自信が自分にある
そこら辺はもう自分より年上のもう仕事の世界で上の人に評価されるのは
それはしょうがないんですけど
関係ない まあ素人たちに評価されてたまるかと
だからみんなに合格する必要ないんです
私は教師をやっている時は
やっぱり仕事柄もう自分の上の人々はたくさんいました
そういう人々には評価されるようには頑張る
生徒たちでもなんかいい加減なことを言ったら
もうすごい攻撃する で
やってみろ できれば 厳しかったんだから
大学だからみんな大人で
言うことを聞かないとかいっぱいあるしね
学校とは随分違いますから
学校でもちょっとちょっと何回ぐらいね
教えてることになって
普通の高校とかね まあほんの一時的でしたけど
まあその時でも聞きたくないとかね
いきなりじゃああんた方は何人いるんですかね
聞きたくない人々は みんな出て行って
はっきり言って出て行けと
私もそんなかゆくないんだと
勉強したくないやつらに教えるぐらい
で言うと みんなおびえて真面目に聞くんです
それから それで自分で決めてしまったんだから
もうもう約束成り立ってます
ちゃんと聞きなさい 聞くべきやと
それで一回授業終わると
それからはもうみんな真剣に来るし
ですから 一応先生たちも信頼できないんだっていう問題にちょっと脱線しましたけど
これもみんなで社会でやった行為の悪い結果で
今の先生たちはまるっきり人格がなくて
信頼できない どうにもならん人々になっていますけどね
それは子供たちに簡単に直せますよ
子供たちはもう仲良くしてあげれば
みんなまた人間に戻りますよ
だから先生ではなくて
我々に必要なのはもうやっぱり人間なんですね
仲のいい人間です ですから
このガリガリの先生たちをね
テキストマニュアルから絶対脱線しない
その人々をもうロボットみたいだからね
人間に戻してもらう 子供たちにはとても簡単にできる
ですから 勉強の一番いい裏技っていうのは
やっぱり先生と仲良くすること
正しく言えば先生を敬うことなんです
お釈迦様の言葉をそのまま日本訳すれば
ガールという言葉を使ってますけどね
尊敬すると  それはまあ
知識の世界で 知識はそんなに難しいことじゃありません
そんな大げさに考える必要もないんです
ただ概念を詰め込むだけのことだからね
脳細胞にはいくらでも概念詰め込めます
順番に詰め込む場合は
ちょっと時間かかるだけのことです
あれもこれもなんでも勉強してみたいなと思ったら何でもできますよ
時間かかるんだからできなくなるだけのことなんです
能力ないわけじゃないんです
医学も勉強して工学も勉強したいなと
できますよ 何のことなく能力はあります
問題は医学を合格して一人前になるためには十年
十年かかると 工学の世界にもまたそれぐらいではないんだけど
かなり時間かかる それでこれ二十歳で頑張ってみればもう四十歳になっているんですね
だから時間ないだけなんですよ
時間がないことに頭が悪いと思っているんだから
頭は本当に悪いんですね
単純に時間がないだけ
ですから 知識についてそんな大げさに考える必要ないんですよ
やればできるというぐらいのことで
でも仏教では知識だけではダメなんですよ
仕事ないんです 知識だけには
本当になんで我々は勉強するんですかね
それは何か仕事を見つけて生きるためなんですよ
そんなどうったことじゃないんです
学校に行って勉強したんだからって
そんな素晴らしい何だかんだも教えてくれる
これこそということじゃないんですよ
ただ まあ人は仕事を何かして生活しなくちゃいけない
ただで食べさせてもらうことはどこにもないんです
ただで住居を提供してくれるとかね
それはありえないんですよ
ただで提供してくれるところはあっても
誰かがそれを作らなくちゃあかんだから
住居は ただでご飯食べさせるところはあるんだと言ったって
誰かがご飯作ってあげなくちゃあかんだから
どこかでお金かかるでしょうしね
ですから この世の中でただで生きられるということは全くもない
どんどん呼吸もただでなくなる可能性ありますでしょ
空気が汚染されてしまうと
呼吸にもお金 今水にお金払っているでしょうに
前はなかったでしょうに
日本は一番きれいな水がある国でしょうに
なのに水にも今お金を払っている
ただじゃないんですよ
もっと人間が頭良くて進歩すると
空気にもお金を払うことになります
まあ昔はただでしたけどね
空気と水ってぐらいは
素晴らしく頭良くて進歩して
それにもお金を払うことになるという
まあそれは置いておいて
まあですから なんで勉強しますかね
一応何か仕事をするためなんですよ
でも仕事は学校の勉強で
知識ではできません それにもう一つやらなくちゃいけないことがありますね
技術 だからお釈迦様はいつでもこの学問と技術 ５
つも合わせて言うんですよ
その二つを身につくべきですよ
学問だけでは食べていられません
先生になるかもしれませんだけど
教師にはなるかもしれませんだけど
世の中みんな教師になったらどうなるんですかね
ですから 学問だけでは生きていられません
技術 技術というものが必要なんです
だから 一番自分が食べていられるのは技術の世界なんですよ
だから随分真剣に使った方がいいんですね
技術の場合は 両方勉強してくださいと
このマングルスッタという経典があります
そちらにこの幸福になる人は
この 2つを獲得しなさいと書いています
まあ覚えていると思いますけど
これは一行なんですが
これ一行目ですけど バーフサッチャンとシッパンチャ
バーフサッチャっていうのは教育
知識を勉強しなさいと
シッパンっていうのは技術のこと
何か技術も身につきなさいよと
それで幸福になるんだよと
もう一行ありまして ヴィナヨーチャススッキト
よく道徳的な人格のある人間になりなさいと
ヴィナヨーチャススッキト
ススッキトヴィナヨ ヴィナっていうのは道徳のことを道徳的な人格のある人間になりなさいと
いくら技術身についたっても
いい加減な人は雇われませんだからね
性格悪い人はもう役に立ちませんだから
だからすごく大事ですよと
学問も必要し 技術も必要し
それが生かせるためには道徳的な人間もなってもらいたいと
その 3つ揃うと もう人間はこの世の中で完全に生きていられます
幸福で生きていられます
それでは私は言いましたので
この人間にはね 知識はいくらでも勉強すればいくらでも勉強できるんだよと
誰にでもできます 天才とかそんなのはありえないんです
みんな天才ですよ ちゃんと乗ればね
このオートバイに 乗り方が下手だからね
それは私が知ったことじゃないんです
だからオートバイ乗り方っていうのは
先生と仲良くすることだけ
それだけのことなんですよ
先生と仲がいい関係あるんだったら
もう何でも勉強できる
それぐらい単純なことでね
失敗するんだから それで何でも勉強できると言っちゃうと
どこまで勉強すればいいかという問題が出てくるんですよ
どこまで勉強すればいいんでしょうかと
それで勉強する欲ができると
人間が勉強するはするはするはもう何キリがなくやっちゃうんですよ
病気になるまでやっちゃうんです
そこはね 必要でしょうかと
から欲にキリがないんだから
もうどうにもならんことで
だからどこまででも勉強してやるぞということもあまり意味がないんです
自分の人生は幸福で幸せで
いわゆる人生は安定するところまで生き方
まあこれで安定だよと
これでいくらかもう安心に生きていられるんだぞというところでやめた方がいいんです
だからどこまで勉強するかということには
簡単な答えは 自分の将来を安定させるところまで
そんな世の中で安定したものは何もないんだけど
一応もう常識的に まあこれぐらい勉強しておけば
まあ食べるものには困りません
困りませんと 仕事は安定するだろうと
そういうところまでやった方がいいんじゃないかなと
ですから まあどこまででも世の中にある知識は何だかんだ勉強する必要はないんで
ほとんど大したことじゃないんでしょうしね
かえって余計なことを勉強するとね
もう頭が働きすぎて全然まとまらなくなっちゃいますよ
あれやこうやでいろんなものを知りすぎちゃうと
結局何もできない人間になってしまう場合もあります
ですから 勉強はあまりしすぎは良くないんですね
自分の人生はもうこれで安定になるんじゃないかなというところで
まあやめた方がいいんですよ
それからももういろいろ勉強することは出てきますけど
まあそれはそれなりに勉強しながらやればいいんですよ
インド文化ではね 仏教ということではないんだけど
人は死ぬまで勉強するべきだよと言ってるんです
それはインド人の欲なんですよ
中国人もなかなかそんな調子がありますけどね
あるエピソードがありまして
このあるバラモン人が
まあまあ 世界にあるすべての知識を学ぶぞと思って学び始めたんだそうで
まあこれは単なるエピソードで
実際にあったことじゃないと思いますけど
で それでその人はいろんな人と喋ってみる
で 勉強する やがて全部知ったことになったんです
誰と話してみたっても
その人を知っていること
自分を知っている また
新しい人に出会って喋ってみたら
その人を知っていること
自分を知っている ああ
私はこの世の中であるすべての知識を学んでいるんだよと
となったところで その人かなり年なんですね
そこである人に出会ったんです
なかなか社会に出て良くない人
その人に喋ってみたら
自分知らないことを何か知ってるんですよ
これはなんかすごい効き目がある
すごい恐ろしい呪文なんですね
呪文文化もありますからね
呪術の文化もインドにありますからね
ヴェーダの4分の1は呪術だからね
あ これ知らなかった まずかったと
それでそのバラモン人が教えてくださいと
私を弟子にしてくださいと言ったら
もうこれはね 人には教えられませんと
いくら頼んでも どう頼んだって教えて教えられません
これは私は特別もう扱っ扱っている知識で
これは人に与えることは無理ですと
ただ この人はもう負けませんね
すべての知識を獲得しようと思っていたんだから
頑張っても弟子入りをお願いするんです
ったらこの人言うんですよ
これは人に喋ると その聞いた人はその場で死にますよと
それぐらい恐ろしい呪文の教えだよ
あんたそれでもやるつもりですか？と
やっぱりそれでも何か知らないで死ぬのは嫌ですよと
だったら死ぬ瞬間で まあそれも勉強しておくんだよと言って
それでも弟子入りと願いするんですね
だったらもう穴を 何のため？じゃあお前も死ぬんだから
私は面倒くさいやと 穴を掘るの
死んだら一応土ぐらいはあげて入れてあげますと
言って本人に穴を掘ってもらったんです
本人がもう堂々と掘るんですよ
知識欲で死んでもいいと
そこで OK ですか？で
じゃあ穴の先に立ってくださいと言って
穴の向こう側から その先生は専属の新しい学問を教えてあげたんですね
それはちゃんと身について終わると
その人は死んでしまったと
そこでまあ 土を入れて埋めて帰っちゃったんだぞという話なんです
だから本人が自分でやった知識全部得たんですけど
それでも何のためかと
だからその物語もね ガチャガチャあれこれとか
何でも勉強しなくてもいいという話になってるんです
で 逆にもう私に教えたと
あんた方 なんで怠けるんですか？と
人は死んだっても 死ぬことも怖がらないで勉強するもんだよということで教えてくれたもの
教えられたエピソードなんですけど
私から見れば逆じゃないかなと思ったんですよ
だからそんなに勉強に真剣にならなくてもいいやと
逆に逆効果になっちゃって
よく教えてくれたね  だから何でも勉強するっていうことはできるんだけど
必要じゃない で 技術の場合はどうですかね
技術の場合は何でもできるってことじゃないんですよ
そのその人にできる技術とできないものはあるんです
でも仕事は技術で得られますよ
技術でなければ仕事はなし
食えません では 世の中にある技術
何でも自分にできますかというとできません
できるものまでできないものもある
ですから 自分にできる技術を身につけてもらう
エンジニアの技術を持っていたっても
音楽の技術は持てないかもしれませんし
そういういろいろありますからね
音楽家であろうとも 決して演奏できない楽器もあるかもしれません
いくら踏ん張っても上手にならないと
そういうふうに技術の場合は向き不向きがあります
学問の場合はないんです
だからみんなそれぞれ仕事を選んでやってるんです
だから 普通のトラックの運転手になった人が医者見て羨む必要ないんです
私も勉強して医者になった方がよかったなと
勉強はできたかもしれませんだけど
医者になれるかならない
それ技術だからね 私にしても
医学っていうのはものすごい簡単にわかるんですよ
どんな専門文章でも 英語であるならば読めるんです
日本語だったら まあ嫌で読めて読みたくない
カタカナばっかりで何言ってるかさっぱりわからない
昨日も遺伝子のなんとかの講義を見たんだけど
もうこれ英語ぐらい書いてくだったら一発で覚えておくのにと思ったんで
全部カタカナばかり 何一つわからない
発音もできないしね まあとにかくそんなことでもいいんですけど
だから医学の専門書であろうとも
自分にも簡単に読める
理解はできる だからといって医者ではありませんし
医者にはなれないと思いますよ
あんな嫌な環境で一生いられるかと思っちゃうと
もうすごく死ぬまで患者さんの泣き声聞きながら
おわくも聞きながら これたまったもんじゃない
仕事に行くんだそう言って病院に行くことだからね
これはもう ということで
まあだから知識は得られますけど
技術は得られないんですね
昔 若い頃はいろいろ手術のものについてあっても
もう過程から全部説明できるんですよ
だけど 私にはあれ取れませんよ
全然 それは知識で 技術は別で
ですから この私たちにはどんな技術も身につくよと言ったら
それはありえないことで
自分に気に入っている
簡単に身につくことができる技術もやってくださいと
それで技術の場合も基準がありまして
この何だかんだ見ると技術を身につけることはかえって危険
かえって危険 試したくなるんだからね
その場合 ですから 余計な技術を身につくということも良くない
それで勉強もたくさんあるんだけど
選ばなくちゃいけない
技術もたくさんあるんだけど
自分に合ってるものを選ばなくちゃいけない
それで選ぶ基準は何なのかと
それは自分だけの試験
自分だけの責任 どうやって選ぶんです？誰も選んでくれません
親が時々いい加減に子供に学問を選ぶんだけど
とんでもないことで これは子供が選ぶべきなんです
何者になるかっていうことは
子供の世界で勝手でいいんです
それで不幸になろうか
幸福になろうか それは勝手にすればいいんです
親が心配して決める必要はない
これは親にできることじゃない
学校の先生にもできることじゃないんですね
何を勉強して何をどんな技術を学ぶかっていうことはね
ですから これは子供にとって大変な問題なんですね
やっぱりその場合は子供も経験もないんだから
なかなか困りますけど
その場合はお釈迦様は一つ基準を教えてあるんですよ
その学問 この技術はあなたのためになるかと
いわゆる仕事になるかと
それで食べていられるかと
それだけ考えなさい それだけではない
まずそれを考えて考えなさいと
ただ好きだからやるんだとかね
そんなことじゃなくて
若者はだいたい音楽なんかやりたいでしょうに
みんな音楽家になりたい
誰もならないでしょうに
だから若い時は誰でも音楽には興味ある
変な音楽なんで気持ち悪いんですけど
若者にはものすごい気持ちいいんです
それで自分も同じことをやりたくなっちゃうんですね
あれはもうちょっと遊びでいいんです
すぐ年取ると嫌になるんだからね
それで才能がなくても困って
仕事もなくて大変に困るんですよ
ですから 何をやりたいと考えた時は
私はこれで一生食べていられるか
いわゆる自分のためになるかということを考える
次に世の中のためになるんでしょうかと
みんなのためになるんでしょうかと
自分の仕事は その 2つで選べばいいんです
そうすると問題ないんです
ですから 余計な知識と余計な技術を学ばないでくださいということになるんです
いらんことはやめてくださいと
仕事にならないものならないものはやめてよと
一生自分に仕事をして生活できるという技術と知識を身につけて身につければ十分です
十二分です 余計ないらんことをやるとかなり人生苦しいんですよ
仕事にも何も関係ないことを一生懸命勉強しちゃうと
仕事に行く使うべき時間さえもなくなっちゃうんですよ
子供よくやるでしょ もう教えるのに授業をやっているのに
裏で隠れて漫画読んでいるとかね
漫画からも知識を得られるかもしれませんだけど
それで勉強に使うべき時間でしょ
だから苦しんじゃうんだよ
後で ですから余計な技術
余計な知識は良くない
例えば私にしたっても
私は日本の知識やいろいろなこと
余計なものでも勉強しちゃうと
説法するときはもうスイスイ言っちゃうかも
言ってはいます もう言ってしまうんで
結局私に関係ないことなんでしょうね
日本の漫才師はもうとんでもない下手やとかね
そんなことどうでもいいことで
私にとってはね 日本人に怒られる
私から見れば冗談の説明までするんですよ
冗談じゃないです それだったらいろいろなんかおしゃれっぽいみたいな
何か言葉のからくりして意味まで言うんです
それはこちらで判断して笑うべきなのに
ああ えらい下手だなと
どちらが下手かと言ってる側か聞いている側かとかね
冗談通じないやとか 余計なこと私の頭に浮かんじゃうんですね
だからその余計な知識を得られなかったらいいのに
私はなんでやというと
この笑う技術と人がなぜ笑うのかとかね
どうすれば笑わせればいいかとか
まあ余計なことをそんな仕事もしていないのに
ちょっと調べちゃう 悪い性格で
それで説法は台無しになる
余計なことを言っちゃって
それ一つの例だけなんですけど
だからまあ あれやこれで余計なことが頭に入っちゃうと
結局役に立たないんですよ
ダメになっちゃうんです
技術の場合も危険な技術いっぱいありますよ
科学研究はすごくいいことなんですけど
電気 まあなんて言いますか
原子の研究も決して悪いことじゃないんだけど
あんまりにも技術を身につけちゃうと爆弾まで作っちゃう
そこで誰かが爆弾を作ることを勉強してみてください
なんかたまに試したくなるんですよ
それで人生が終わっちゃうんです
勉強するときが面白いとか言って
危険な技術を間違ってでも身につけない方がいいんです
結構ですよ まあ例えば電池で
あの 何かダイナマイトでもでもね
火をつける方法ありますよと
ありますけどね リモートコントロールでもできますよと
携帯電話でもできます
そんなことやり方を覚えてみてください
やりたくなるんですよ
あと うまくいくかないかと
それは人間っていうのはそんなもんですよ
ですから 決めていらん技術といらん知識
自分の仕事にならないものはもうきれいさっぱり捨てるんです
勉強しないことにします
だから このなんで我々の世界が苦しんでいるかというと
みんなこのいらん知識で
いらない技術で自然破壊している
環境を破壊している 人類を殺している
飢えている人間が食べるものなくて
これいらん技術いらん知識だからでしょう
技術発展といえば みんな地球上の人間がお腹いっぱい食べて生活するはずでしょうに
みんなに住むところがいる
あるはずでしょうに 結果どうですかね
住むところはない人々の方が多い
食べるものはない人々の方が多い
平和で生きている人々の数が少ない
飢えている人々 殺される人々
すごくたくさんいるんじゃないですか
すべていらん技術といらん知識なんです
そこで悪い知識についてちょっと一言おしゃべりしたい
悪い知識って何なのか
まあ悪い技術っていうのは
まあまあ それほど世の中ではまああるとは思いませんね
まあ大体武器作るぐらい
麻薬の作り方とかね まあそれぐらいのもんですよ
毒の作り方とか まあ結局生物兵器はどうやって細菌をどうやって作るかっていうぐらいのことで
まあ悪い技術っていうのは
まあ一応まあまあそこら辺で終わっちゃいます
でも悪い知識はかなりたくさんあります
かなりたくさんあります
で 知識というのは一見かっこよく見えるんですよ
勉強だから 本読むことだから一見かっこよく見えます
でもちょっと調べてみないと
だからどんな知識でもかっこよく見えます
例えばアラビア語を勉強しているんだと言ったら
あ かっこいいじゃんとなるんですよ
私はアラビア語じゃなくて
アメリカンインディアンの言葉を勉強しているんだ
ああ よかったな すごいなということになるんですよ
言語の場合は問題ないんですけど
だから知識っていうのは
どんな知識もかっこよく見えます
でも だからといって何でもやってはいけない
知識から怒り 憎しみ 戦い
余計な欲 殺し 戦争 そういうものに間接的でも影響を与えるものだったら
必ず悪い知識は捨ててください
あるんですよ 勉強で怒りを育てる
学問で 学問で嫉妬を育てる
学問で憎しみを育てる
例えば歴史の場合はそうでしょう
日本も正しく歴史を教えてないし
韓国も正しく歴史を教えてないんです
憎しみを育てること こちらは嘘をつくこと
という両方でしょう だから歴史はやめた方がいいんです
それはいい加減なこと
それから差別 勉強した結果で自分が差別主義者になってしまえば
あるんですよ そんなものは
例えば皆様 日本の方々だから
日本人の歴史やら謂われやら
もうどんどん勉強すると
そういう学問本を書いている人々は
なんだかすごくこの日本民族というのはすごい世界一の誰にも負けない唯一な存在や
そういう方向に学問を持っていくんですよ
馬鹿のいいところなんですよ
地球の人類はみんな単なるホモ・サピエンスで人間なんです
いろいろ民族にはいろいろ歴史
謂れがあるのは当たり前のことで
だからすごくクールな気持ちで淡々と客観的に勉強しなくちゃあかんところは
すぐ主観的になって ちょっと舞い上がって余計に評価して教えちゃうと
勉強する本人もその気になっちゃうんです
その気になっちゃって
私は日本人だからということで人を軽蔑しよう
差別しようということになっちゃうんですね
だから日本人の歴史を勉強するのはすごい正しいことで
日本民族はどこから来て
どんなふうに発展したんですかとかどうか
何に何人混ぜてるんでしょうかとかね
それは別に悪いことじゃないんだけど
それでもって もし差別意識なんかは優越感とかなんとか出てくるんだったらやめた方がいい
これは危険 それは仏教的な立場
勉強した結果 みんな同じだよと
みんな人間で一生懸命頑張ってるというふうな
この平和な思考 慈しみの思考が出てくるんだったら
いい勉強で で 今だから言うんだけど
私たちは唯一の神を信仰しているんだというふうに言っている人々がいますね
そこで神から授けてくれたもう本もあります
神の言葉も持ってますよ
一見読んでみるとなかなかいいこともありますよ
そこで我々はいいことを言ってるなと感じることは
どんな人間もわかることなんです
神の言葉ではなくて だって私たちにも納得できるんだから
そこで誰でもわかる 納得できる道徳というもの
いろいろあって それでどんどんいくんですよ
この絶対的な神にはもう完全に報復するべきですよと
奉仕するべきですよと
それで一番悪い罪は神を裏切ることやと
どうして世の中で神を信仰する人と信仰しない人がいるんだよと
そこから何ですかね 人を差別する
それで殺してもいいということになっちゃうんです
だから世の中で殺し合ってるんです
昔のカトリック教でも堂々とそれ教えていたんです
二つに人間を分ける ビリーバーズ
ノンビリーバーズと 神を信仰する人々
信仰しない人々 そんなものは学問でも何でもないでしょうに
教えっていうのは人類に語るべきなんです
ブッダの教えのように
信仰者と信仰しない人と区別していないでしょうに
ですから この我々にはこの
だから頭が悪くなる この間何か人を捕まえて
爆弾テロをした人がね
ちょっとテレビでちょっと見たんですけど
その人はもうとんでもない爆弾テロを起こしちゃって
もう何人も人を殺しちゃって
もう裁判に問われるんだけど
威張ってるんですね まあそれはもう神様が
もう人が生き死にが神様が決めるものですよとかね
ひとかけらも反省の気持ちはない
たくさん人を殺したのに
だからその人々は何を学んだんですか？です
人間として学ぶべきでないものを学んじゃったんですよ
だから爆弾テロを起こして
自分ももう殺されるんだけど
他のテロたちにもこれ言うんだから
だから他のテロでも威張るでしょうね
やっぱりあの人はもう捕まったんだと
裁判に問われて それから刑務所か
まあ処刑か 終身刑にはなるでしょうとかなんとかで
でもやっぱりめげてはいけませんと
あの人のようにしっかりした信仰を持つべきですよということになっちゃうんですね
だから この人殺しに影響を与える人に
人に不幸を作る知識はすごいたくさんにこの世の中にあります
ものすごいたくさんあります
ダイエットの知識にしたっても結構あります
痩せる方法の知識にしても
かなり人をダメにするものっていうのはあります
だからそういう知識はいっぱいありますから
気をつけて自分たちが判断しなくちゃいけない
何でも勉強するんじゃない
まあどうせ人間っていうのは感情的にはすごい弱いんだから
勉強したものは実況したくなる
技術身についたらどこかでやりたくなる
免許証取ったら運転したくなるでしょうに
用があってもなくても
だから技術やら知識やら身についたら使いたくなるのは人間の弱みなんです
感情なんです これはどうにもならん
ですから 悪いものは身につけない方がいいんです
それで仏教から言うのはこういうこと
悪いことは悪いと先に判断する能力を持ってほしい
ちょっと勉強している途中でわかるんですよ
もう反論出してみて 質問出してみて
自分でも考えてみて 例えば仏教のことだから言いますけど
ある仏教の仏教の人々
私にこう言ったんですけど
このあるブッダが如来がすべての世界も宇宙も人間もすべてもう如来の分身で作っているんだよと
だから如来はまずあの何て女人かな
もう如来たちを作って
それから菩薩とのグループを作って
不動さんやら地蔵さんからいろいろ作っていて
人間も作っていてとかね
全部分身で同じやとそこでと言っても
我々人間として苦しんでいるんだからと
ですから それはもうあなた方はちゃんと修行する必要あるんだよと
そのために作っているんだよと
私は言ったのアホじゃないかという
あの如来は自分勝手に作って
勝手に苦しませて アホでない限りはこんなことしないやと
なんで何か何か問題でもあったんですか？最初から自分を自分が分身して現象世界を作ったことはね
何か問題あったんだよ
だからいい加減なことを言うな
だからまあ そうやってものすごい知識っぽく聞こえるんですよ
すべて仏様の分身の人
ああ なんて素晴らしい言葉ですかと
ちょっと調べてみると
あまりにもくだらん理屈
成り立たない話になるんです
それは同じ仲間の宗教だから言ったんですけど
全く関係ないことを言っちゃったんで
大変きついことになりますから
それ出しましたけど だからちょっと反論してみれば
この論理的なガタガタということ
非道徳的なことっていうのは見出せるんですよ
例えば みんな如来の分身であるならば
殺人犯よ その人を威張るんで
私はもう如来の分身で
私は殺人犯を犯すようになっているんだと
それであんた方わかるでしょ？と言っちゃえばどうします？あんたことわかるでしょ？怒りはよくない
人殺しはよくないと あんた方によく真面目に頑張るでしょうにと
で 私はお釈迦様 如来の使者になってますと言えばどうなるんですかね
だからそういうすべてを如来のなんとか分身だと言っちゃうと
なぜ人殺しとは悪い なぜ嘘をついては悪いということを成り立たなくなるんですよ
だから道徳否定しちゃうんですよ
でも その師匠学問を作る人々はそこまで頭が良くないんだ
動かないんだから まあ何か言って終わっちゃう
みんな言うことはいい加減だからね
お釈迦様おっしゃる言葉以外はもう全部いい加減だから
そんな大したことないんです
まあだから何か勉強する場合はちょっと調べる必要があります
ですから結論で言いますけど
鵜呑みは良くない これはお釈迦様はっきりしているんです
鵜呑みするなかれと 正しい教えかないか自分で判断しなさいと
ですから理性持ちなさいと
それはもうはっきりと釈迦様がおっしゃることで
たとえ私がブッダで悟っているんだと言っても
信じるなよと バカみたい
調べてみなさいよということを
正しいかないかと というふうに
この人間を幸福にするために
その理性をきちんとした理性を持つ
自分で判断してみる 反論もしてみる
嫌な教えだとわかったらすぐ捨てる
たまたまこちらに行くと
いろんな宗教 宗教団体に子供たちは引っ張られます
まあ引っ張られたって
その時面白いこと言ったってもいいんだけど
すぐなんか変だなとわかったら
すぐその瞬間でやめたと
何やと それぐらい勇気が必要なんです
あんた この宗教やめたらもうひどい目にあって脅すんじゃないよと
人と言えば これは脅しでしょうと
私を脅されたから ただそれ言ったんですよ
あんた この宗教はもう批判してね
浸透しなきゃ もうとんでもないことになるな
そういう例もありますかと聞いたところで
例いくつか言ったんですね
暴力団に殴られた いじめられた例
あ わかりますと あんた方暴力団体でしょ
入りたくないんだからね
勝手にしなさいよと 宗教団体ではなくて
私は怖くないんだ 君らの身のは危ないんだよ
これから気をつけなさいよと
だからもうもう悪いとわかったらすぐもう捨てちゃえばよろしいし
で  1回目は終わるために
最後に試験って何なのかと
受験って何なのかと まあ試験受験というのは学校ではね
やっていること 自分の能力をチェックすること
それは相手にしかできませんね
私の数学能力をチェックすることは
私より数学能力ある人にしかできないんですね
当たり前であって そこで試験するということは
自分で自分の戦いなんですよ
私にどこまでできるかなとかね
どこまで進歩してるかなとかね
自分をチェックすることであって
他人にチェックしてもらうことじゃないんです
たとえ先生が じゃああんた 100点満点だと言って
ああ 先生から 100点もらったぞと言ったって
とんでもないことでしょうに
先生は 100点くれてないんですよ
自分がもらったんです
だから試験というのは自分でどこまで走れるか
というぐらいのことで
例えば手でこうやってすれば何て言いますか
はい 腕立て 腕立ては何回自分にできるかということのことであって
誰かに褒めて もう誰かに書いてもらう必要ないでしょ
自分で例えば 8回やったとします
そばにいる人が じゃあ君は 100回腕立てできることでことでことで承認しますとかね
どうでもいいことで そんなことは自分に 100回できるんだったら
ですから 試験でもう 100点取るか 80点取るかということは自分が取るんであって
向こう側からもらうものじゃないんですよ
ですから 受験というのは
試験というのは テレビゲームとコンピューターゲームと何の変わりもないんです
単なる自分の腕立て どれぐらいできるかと
自分に何キロ走れるかと
自分のことをチェックすることなんですよ
だからそれを覚えておけば
どんな試験ももう楽しくて楽しくて
もうたまらない状態になるんです
試験日 近寄ってくると
もうもうたまらないんですよ
それでみんなもう私より頭がいいんだからね
相手を作るんですよ あの組織に認めてもらう
あの学校に認めてもらうとか
敵作るんですね それで受験はもう地獄になります
例えば  医者の免許ってそれほど厳しくはないんですけど
でも例えば弁護士の免許とかはね
すごい厳しいんですね
それで向こう側を敵に回しちゃうんですよ
悪口を言うんですね この試験制度は何なのかとかね
どうせろくでもない制度だから
そんなの放っておいたっていいでしょうに
単純なことだから これで人間の能力を測れるかどうか
どうでもいいことで これは試験というのは
自分にどれぐらい走れるか
自分に腕立てはどれ何回できるかという自分だけのことであって
だからテレビゲームにしたっても同じことでしょうに
勝ったってもどうしたことないし
負けたってもどうしたことないんですよ
うまく指が動くとかなり高い点数は出せるでしょうね
ゲームで うまく動かなかったらもうすぐ負けちゃってゲームオーバーになるだけで
ですから このような試験というのはそれぐらい単純なこと
人間というのはもう試験する側というふうに
敵とえらく高く見る それでできなくなっちゃいます
それだけじゃなくて 一緒に試験を受ける人も敵に回しちゃうんです
ライバル意識を持つ もうできないんですよ
能力も何もなくなっちゃうんです
それで受験地獄やらね
いろいろ不幸な出来事やら
お受験に母親が苦しむとかね
ああいう人々はもうまとめて病院に連れて行った方がいいんですよ
もう病気なんです ものすごいバカバカらしいんです
例えば幼稚園にも 400人がもう出してますよ
入れると言われるのは 50人だよと
すごい もう厳しいやな
競争が激しいことであって
他の子どもたちに対して汚くてライバル意識を持つと
それだけで自分がもう失格でしょ
もう失格だから 私もそういう競争的な試験を受けたこともありますけど
選ぶのは一人や二人やとかね
200 300人ぐらい受けると
自分の国はかなり競争率は並みじゃないんです
で 私も一緒にみんな友達としてしゃべったり
冗談を言ったり からかったりしている
そこでえらいライバル意識をみんなに
みんな気持ち持ってる人に見えるんです
だから私は自分勝手で
あなたは負けもう決まってる
あなたも負けもう決まってると
そこでみんな試してみたら
まあ冗談でゲームで取ってるのは私だけなの
じゃあ私は勝ちますと
まあ大丈夫やと 簡単だったんですね
人もいるんだけど 自分が何のことなく選ばれちゃって
もう決まってますよ ただの自分だけのゲームだから
自分がその面接やら試験を受ける人々とどんな対話するかっていうぐらいのことでしょうに
そこでうまくいって 自分がそのもういわゆる人気をもう気に入られてもらう
試験っていうのはそんなもんなんです
過去試験であろうか もう口頭試験であろうが何であろうと
日本の大学で博士課程に入るときは
もうくだらない試験があったんだけどね
まあ過去試験もあったんだけど
私から見れば自分の大学入学試験
高校試験のレベルではなかったんですけどね
できなかったのは漢文なんで
漢文できないのは当たり前だからね
みんな高校で勉強してる漢文のいくつか出しちゃって
これはまあ日本語訳しなさいと
これは私にできません
まあ漢字はいくつかいくつか分かったんですけど
難しい仏教的な感じでね
分かったんだけど 一部は書いたんだけど
まあうまくいってないとは知っていて
それで英語の先生に言われて
英語なんかもう子供みたいな
どっかの仏教のテキストからすごい難しいと勘違いして書いてるところですけど
私には夢で聞いたっても日本語訳できるぐらい
まあそこでまあからかうんですよ
このある先生のお坊さんが
まあ漢文なんかダメですね
ああ それはまあ決まってます
私も何のこと それはもう決まってますよ
じゃあざまあみろということなんですよ
漢文ダメだからもうあなたはもうダメってこと言えませんだから
それでそれは先生 まあ決まってますよ
じゃあ行ってみろと 向こうは執行されるんで
結局は あんた何を研究するのは
こういうことを説明するんだけど
分かってくれない なぜ
これはまあ教授といってもね
まあ日本のことだから
まあどうせ資格ないでしょうと
わかってくれないくれない
だから他の先生方はまあ一応東大出たりといろいろわかってる人もいましたけどね
でも一番偉い人は全然わからないんですね
そこでこれは初期仏教
early ブッディズムってこれ何なのかと聞くんですね
言ってもあれ あの あの清浄仏教でしょ
だから私は腹が立ったんだけど
これはよくもバカもんで
大学でもね もう口頭試問
質問なんとかでもうプレジデント座ってるんではないかと思って
そんなこと言ったら自分が負けるんだからね
そうなんです 先生 これ清浄仏教ですよ
ああそう 清浄仏教 それで OK です
だからそんなもんですよ
試験というのは 向こうはこちら測るならこちらで向こう測っちゃえばいいんだからね
だから単なるゲームで
遊びでうまくいくんです
試験というのは だから
なんで子供たちはこんな楽しいことがあるのに苦しむかっていうことはもう羨ましいんですよ
私も試験を受けたいぐらいなんですけど
あんな楽しいことないのに
人を馬鹿にするためにはそれほどいいチャンスがないのに
なかなか出てこないんですよ
ですから すごい楽しいことなんですよ
試験というのは だからこの相手に調べられる
相手に測られると思っちゃうと
もう怖くてもうもう立ちませんよ
立てません その上 これぐらいライバルもいるんだぞと思ったら
もう負けたと もう終わってます
だから誰も敵がない ライバルない
これは俺に何回腕立てができるかと
ということで それで 100回やれというんだったら
チェックする人は黙々とでもやらなきゃいいでしょう
数数字だけ数えれば あるいは膝と体をつけたままで
もうもう 41  43  45言えば
まだ見るとまた一生懸命やればいいということで
単純なんですよ それ全てということじゃないんだから
だって私はそうやっていろいろする賢い知恵作って
どんな試験も合格していけたんだけど
結局こんなもんだから
今は何の役にも立ってないというのは立ってないしね
あれほど競争していろいろ仕事のいろんな立場やいろいろ得たんだけど
全部辞めちゃったしね
で みんななんてことをするんですかと
あんなに難しいことをあんたにももう与えているのにとかね
みんな腕かし間違ってるのに
なんで平気で捨てるんですかとか
まあ面白くないんだと
私は何のことな ですから
まあ試験というのはそんなに難しいことではなくて
自分の腕立ての回数のことなんです
誰かが見張ってるんだったら
その時だけ真面目になって
あっち向くと数だけ数えるという
それでうまくいくぐらいのもんです
と  そこら辺で一旦休憩して
あの 試験についてもう少々とお話をします
それから仏教のところもちょっと説明します
では 休憩いたします では
試験というのは自分との戦いであって
自分で自分のゲームだと説明しました
誰も敵やと思っちゃうと試験はできない
どうせ試験の場合は人が判断することだから
その人はどんな基準を持ってるかとね
どれぐらいやってあげれば機嫌が良くなるかという
そこは自分で計算して
まあそれはやってあげるぐらいのことで
どんな試験でも合格できると思います
それで 世の中にまた試験もいろいろあるんですよ
くだらない試験もあります
いじめの試験もあります
落第目的してセットする試験もあります
で それから受験者にちょっと見栄張ってやろうではないかと
というふうなできる作る試験もあります
そこで受験したらもう堕落させるんだぞというふうな試験も世の中ではあります
ということは 試験について一番前の話に何かまた戻ったような感じなんですけど
そこら辺もちょっと覚えておいた方がいいんですよ
くだらん試験というのは
みんなやってるでしょ
何て言いますか リモコンで動く車ありますね
おもちゃの あちらの競争やらね
それぞれ資格やらあるんですよ
取ったってどうったことないんですけどね
そうやってもういろんなくだらんことに合格取ってるんだとかね
もう免許を取ってるんだとかね
そんなのはどうでもいいことでね
さて くだらん試験もあります
世の中で あ 何でしたっけ？ヨーヨー
前あったんですよ 何年か前で
まあヨーヨーは人気で人気で
それでヨーヨーのいろいろ使い方なんて
これまた何段階 何段階とかね
あって もう一生懸命子供たちやってますけどね
まあくだらんといえばくだらんし
まあ遊びで言えば遊びですからね
まあしょうがないんですけど
楽しければ楽しいことじゃなくて
あらゆる技を身について
そのそのその段階 何段階となることに
まったくくだらない競争的な試験
わざと自分で作って苦しんでるんですよ
遊びなのに だからヨーヨーも苦しみに持っていくんだから
もう普通の学校の勉強
試験なんかはもう言うところじゃないんですよ
そうやって世の中にいろいろゲームみたいなものもあるんだけど
日本人っていうのは それをまたなんとかもう試験制度に持っていく
で 苦しむ 数字であろうが花であろうが
もう何でももう試験に揃う
なんか頭が悪いと心が汚すぎかどこか分からないんですよ
なんか人のこと見下してるんですかと
遊んで楽しくて何が悪いんですかね
だから気楽に楽しく もう人生楽しんで
いろんな技を身につくっていうことはもう認めない
遊びに剣道やると思ったら
それはうまくいかないんですよ
もう 何々段と決まってるんだから
結局地獄になっちゃうんです
これはまあ一般的にはあんまり良くない性格ですね
基本的な思考で何か間違いあると思いますね
まあいじめの試験といったのは
それも子供たちに結構はめられると思いますよ
なんかもう自分が勉強してるんだったら
もうすぐ答えをこれですよと
まあ出せるのはいいんだけど
なんかもう答えがもうどうしても選べないとか
もう何選んだって間違えるようにとか
あらゆるからくりするんですね
試験の質問の場合は それは単なる相手いじめでね
これはもう受験者にもどうにもならんですけどね
だからそれもわかって
あの先生の質問がどうせいじめだとわかったらね
いい加減にやっちゃえばいいんで
その場合は 時々ありますよ
質問は出ますけど 答えがないと
あの質問が間違ったんだ
最近もあったでしょうに
大学入試試験とかなんとかとか
質問が間違っていましたとかね
だからその質問を作った人々っていうのは人格が悪いんですよ
単なるいじめなんです
自分が知ってるんだぞと
お前らできれば答えてみろと
冗談じゃないでしょ 人の能力を測ることだから
こういう答えだよと あんた知ってるんですか？という態度でしょうに
正しい試験というのは
ですから 本当にこの本気でやらなくなくてはいけない試験なのに
その中はどうせ質問の中で一つ二つ間違っていたんだとかね
例えば四選択六選択になった場合は全部ダメやとかね
あるいは正しい言葉 答えが二つあったとかね
もし頭がいい人で正しい答えを二つ見つけたらどうするんですかね
その人は日課表に鉛筆で入れすぎちゃうでしょうね
そうするとそれは失格に計算するんですね
とんでもないことなんです
だから そういういじめ
試験 見栄の試験もあります
落第目的の試験もありますね
これは弁護士試験とかね
落第させること目的で
まあガチャガチャ言葉のからくりやら
もう書けないものやらいろいろやっちゃいますよ
それわかったらすぐ合格できる
どうせ質問する人の頭明確じゃないんですよ
その場合は だから私だったら合格してみせます
そういうわざと落第させるために
ですから その場合は落第する場合は相手がどうしても書けない
答えられない質問を出すしか方法ないんです
その場合は相手に対して訴えられます
こんなことは書けますかと
答えられますかと ということね
だからまあ世の中では
まあ私はちょっと日本の社会を考えて思ったんですけど
落第目的の試験もどうせあります
だからそんな試験受けて落第したってもどうったことはない
もう一回やればいいんです
どうせ向こうの目的は落第させることだから
だから何回何回チャレンジしてみればいいというぐらいなことで
そこでこの受験者を堕落する試験は何なのかと
それはね まあまあ あまりはやっぱり例っていうのはね
それほどないんですけど
今まで試験になってないんですね
例えば一気に酒はどれぐらい飲めるかどうかね
30 分以内でラーメン何杯食えるかとかね
気持ち悪い試験ばっかりなんですよ
もう 食い大会とかね そうやって飲み大会とかね
そういうところで優勝決めると １
時間でもう 20杯ラーメンを食ったんだよと
まあ考えれば人のことも
食べた人のことも気持ち悪くなるんですよ
何のためこんなことをやるんですかと
だから その人も一つの試験だから
それにその準備いっぱいするでしょうね
なんか最近テレビでよくあるんですよ
このもう想像できないほどのものを食わせて食わせて
それであんたもう優勝
あんたは落第とかね だから堕落するんですよ
受ける側もあらゆる工夫をしてたくさん食べるようにいろんなことをしたりするするんだから
それでパチンコで必ずもう玉が出る噂やら方法とかね
そんなものを習って受験したっても
それも正式的な試験ではないかもしれませんだけど
試験は試験ですからね
そういうのはもう堕落する試験
あるグループに入るためには
まああんた この人と喧嘩して勝てれば入れてくれるぞと
という場合もある それも試験でしょうね
それで相手を選ばれたら
それで喧嘩しなくちゃいけない
で 自分が勝てなくちゃいけない
勝ったら まあいいわ 入れてくれるぞと
そんなだったら最初から見入りたくないと言えばいいんです
入れたいと言うんだから
そんなことチャレンジさせてますけどね
カジノの上手くもうできるような
カードのいろんなもう上手になるようなことをやらと
カードのからくり上手になればなるほど
人生は危険なんですよ
堕落するんです ですから
マジックやらゲームの分はまあいいんですけど
マジックでなんかカードのいろいろからくり見せたりして
みんな笑わせちゃうとかね
まあそれは楽しみだから
それは悪くはないんですが
本当にカジノの世界になってくると
もうかなりカードのからくり
ルーレットのからくりとかいろいろやってますからね
そこら辺でもうまくいくぞと思って
自分がもうそういう試験を受けたりという場合
これはもう堕落試験で絶対受けてはいけない試験ということになる
試験はそのように様々があります
皆様が思っているような高校試験だけ試験ではありません
もう死ぬまであらゆる試験があります
だからまあ 試験は楽しい遊びです
それで自分の役に立つ試験は受けて
楽しく生きていればいいんです
それであの試験の問題は終了いたします
そこでこのまあ ちょっと仏教の話にはなります
で 人間よく人を測りたくなるんだけど
結局自分が何者かも知ってないでしょうに
自分が何者かも知らないのに人を判断する
それも試験なんですね
あの人はもうインチキや
あの人は嘘つきや あの人はもう嫉妬深いわ
あの人はもう性格悪くて
私はなかなか付き合いたくはないとかね
そういうふうに人を判断する
では あなたは何者ですかと聞いてみてください
あんたは一度も嫉妬 嫉妬したことがないんですかと
嘘ついたことはないんですかと
自分の性格もわからないのに
他の性格を判断して試験しようとする
それはものすごい悪い罪だとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
人のことをうんうんと判断することは
それは無理で不可能だと
真理わからない馬鹿どもたちがそんなことをするんだと
この世の中で完全な嫉妬人間はいるわけじゃない
完全な怒り人間もいるわけじゃない
完全な欲人間もいるわけじゃないんです
全く嘘をつく人間もないし
嘘ばっかりつく人間もいないんです
まあ強いて言えば 完全な善人もいないし
完全な悪人もこの世の中でいないんです
では人間何なのかというと
その場でその場で反応する機械だけなんです
例えば 自分より何か上手な人に会うと嫉妬の反応をする
その人がない場合はその反応はない
ただそれだけ 誰かに嫉妬したんだからといって
この人は嫉妬深い人だ
まあ嫌な人やと言っちゃうと
それは良くないんです
そんな判断できるはずがないんです
怒ったんだからといって
あの人は怒りっぽいやと
それ良くないんですよ
ある場面に出会って怒ったんであって
違う場面では怒らないでしょうに
例えば 旦那に向かってカンカン怒っている奥さんがものすごく怒っている最中で
子供が何か言っちゃうと
あ 何ですか？と優しい顔で聞くんだから
瞬時に 人間というのはそんなもんなんですよ
そのそのものに これについて怒ったんだからって
何についても怒るということはないんですよ
だから何についても怒るんだったら
これは精神的な病気で
もう世界ではもうなかなかみんなと一緒に生活はできないんですね
何にも嫉妬することだったら
犬にも嫉妬する 猫にも嫉妬すると
おばあさんにも嫉妬して
自分の子供にも嫉妬するんだったらもう病気でしょ
まあもう人生終わっちゃいますよ
そんな人間いないんだから
大体は だから人を試すなよと
判断するなよと それ自体
あなたは無知ということ
因果法則わからないということです
例えば子供が喧嘩したんだと
やっぱりこの子はいつでも喧嘩
そんなことないんですよ
喧嘩も売る相手がいたんだから
こちらは買っちゃっただけかもしれませんし
こちらが喧嘩を売る性格があったって
向こう買わなかったら喧嘩にならないし
だから子供が喧嘩を売る人であろうが
買う側であろうか それ 2つ合わないと喧嘩にならないんですよ
だから喧嘩したんだからといって
喧嘩好きな人だというふうに決めつけることはできません
なのに人間というのは
そんなまげわな何も観察しない
我が自分のことをわからないんだから
観察できないでしょうに
自分が何者かはっきりしないんだから
で 人を判断する それほど世の中で悪いことはないんですよ
それがもう罪の中でももうものすごい重い罪で
そういう人には成長は不可能ということになっているんです
人格成長は不可能ということは悟れません
徳積むことも不可能になるんですよ
だから大変な危険なことなんです
いつでも我々は進歩できるように心構え持たないと
心構えがないと 信奉してくしなくても
それは別の話で 走るか走らないかということは
とにかくトラックにいないと
ダメなんですよ ですから
この自分が好き勝手に
あの人はこういうもの
この人はこういうものだと
これで私はものすごくもうかなり大変苦しんでいるんだから
もうこれももう相手にもういろいろな個人的な悩みいっぱいあるんですよ
私は人を判断しないんだけど
向こうの頭のバカ作戦にもいろんな人を判断して
だってそうでしょうと
私に見てあんたが悪いんだよという反応でしょ
私は それで私との人間関係もなくなっちゃうし
私 その嫌な人間関係は持ちたくないし
だからといって もうそれやって人を切り捨てるということは
出家者としては失格でしょうし
誰にももうまあ無差別に無分別で協力して助けてあげなくちゃいけないし
何言われたっても だからえらく困っちゃうんですよ
この人も助けてあげちゃいけないんだけど
この人は強引に自分の判断に私を引っ張ろうとしているのではないかと
でも そのそのことをする
その人が間違っているのではないかと
ですから とにかく人を判断すると
全くの成長はできなくなるんです
だからまあ我々は向上したいと成長したいと
より優れた より立派な人間になりたいと思うならば
人を判断することを決めつけることはもうやめた方がよろしいんですよ
いわゆる試験しない方が
試験は不可能です あ 今怒ったと
今あんた怒ってるでしょ？と言ってもいいんですよ
その場で怒ってるんだったら
故にあなたは怒りやと言ったらダメなんです
怒った人も次の瞬間で笑う可能性ありますから
すべて条件によりけりと理解してほしい
そうすると自分のこと何々こと私もわかりませんと
条件によって私は怒るかもしれませんし
嫉妬するかもしれませんし
優しい人になるかもしれませんし
どうでもろくでもない人格やと
みんなの人格はそういう人格なんですよ
まあもう多重人格じゃない
無数人格なんです 出会うものについて
それなりの顔を見せちゃう
その条件変わったらまた変わる
そうやって我々の人格っていうのは
もうじりじりと瞬時に瞬時に変わっちゃうんですよ
だから回転する 変わるんだと言っていても
成長するわけじゃないんです
人格っていうのはもう多数人格でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる
これが回ってるんですよ
ミラーボールみたいに
いっぱい面があるんですよ
これまた小さいだったら数えられますけど
あまりにもバカでかいミラーボールですよ
つかめないほど だからどれぐらい影みをつけているかとわかったもんじゃないんです
だからそれを仏教では整理して
これぐらいこれぐらいと整理してやりますけど
私たちにとってはわからないほど
もう多数人格なんです
ですから 自分でも多数人格で
人のことは一つの人格で判断することはどれほど間違っているかと
ということで 試験は良くないというのが仏教の立場なんです
だから試験しない人間になったということは
すごい立派な人格者なんです
人は判断しないと それだったらものすごい人格者なんですよ
簡単に得られますよ ちょっとわかれば人はいつ怒るかと
それは怒ることに出会ったら怒っちゃうんだよと
なんで嫉妬するんだと
その場で嫉妬するんだよと
ただそれだけやと 子供たちも同じこと
喧嘩する場合 その場で喧嘩したんであって
他の場だったら遊んでると
それだけのことを理解しておけば
因果法則やと条件反射やと
人間というのは それですごい人格者になります
それでこの試験する機能に仏教用語ではこういう言葉を使います
あの たくさんありますが
正しい試験には別なパーリ語があります
それは何か法律で使っているような言葉がいくつかありまして
この 悪い試験の場合は皆様知っている言葉があります
マーナという言葉があります
マーナは日本語では慢ですね
誰かが書いてください
慢を まあ漢文ではね 漢字ではそういう漢字当ててますけど
で これみんな知ってる言葉で高慢という言葉知ってますね
高慢と書く場合 この漢字使いますね
でも本当は高は関係なくて
慢という言葉を仏教は使うんですよ
慢というマーナっていうのは
この測るという動詞から作ってるんですよ
で これもややこしい 尊敬するという場合もマーネティという動詞なんですけど
で これはミナティミナーティという動詞から出てくる
ミナティなんで慢になるかって
私もわかってないんですけどね
で  まあそこまで言語文化は覚えてないんで
とにかく測るという動詞から出てくるんですね
で なんで測るかで これエゴなんですよ
私がいるんだ 私が というエゴからこの測っちゃうんですよ
だから慢の中でも一番人間にものすごい悪い
とんでもない計りはアスミマーラなんです
書けないんだ アスミマーラということなんですね
私がいるんだぞというエゴ
自己 それがもう修行して瞑想して覚らない限りはもう破れないんです
幻覚なんです それが 私がいるんだぞということは
これは見ていると私が見るんだぞという幻覚が起こる
聞くと私が聞いているんだよという幻覚が起こる
概念ですよ 私がというこの概念がやがてもう化け物なんですけど
本物のように我々を脅すんです
だから幻覚だとわかれば大丈夫ですけど
やっぱりそれはちょっと自分を観察しないと
この幻覚は破れない アスミマーナという幻覚を破ったら
もう悟りの世界なんです
私がいるんだということ
では そこまで 今日は説明できませんので
私たちはこうやって人を測るんですね
自分より同じやと あっ
あの人 あっ 私と同じやと
という あの何慢ですかね
それは 日本語で 同じというは
まあ上等とは言わないね
上等じゃなんとか慢ですよ
同格やと ですから ああ
あの人は仲間ですよと
まあ同じですよと 私と同じですよとかね
と同じだと思うことも
もう試験しているんで
自分が相手を判断しているんです
自分という尺度で 私と測ってみれば同じやと
来てないんだと 仏教はもう品がないんだと
測るなよと 同じだと思うことさえも良くないんですよ
それでもう一つあります
シーラマー それは自分が低いと衰えていると
相手よりは あの人はもう私よりはすごいと
私よりはかっこいいと
私よりはできてるんだと
言って なんか気持ち悪い気持ちになるんですよ
それで自分という尺度で測ってみれば
向こうはちょっと一つ一つ上になっちゃうと
それはもう だから自分が低くなるでしょ
ああ 私がダメや あの人はすごいやと思っちゃうんです
そう思ってはいけません
品が悪い 測ってはいけません
次の専門のことはちょっと思い出せません
これはもうまあ 私が上やと思うこと
ああ あの人より私の方が上手だと
あの人より私の方が綺麗やと
あの人より私には力があるんだと
あの人より私はできてるんだと
あの人より私は金持ちやと
そうやってごちゃごちゃ考えること
とにかく悪い性格なんですよ
これは精神的にはすごく暗くなるんで
どちらにしたって 大体一般的にみんな知ってるのは
この高慢のウッチャマーナのことだけなんです
高慢 でも自分が惨めやと思うこともマーナなんですよ
私は惨めや 何もできないんだっていうのは
これとんでもない ものすごい品のない
ものすごい良くない自覚なんですね
だから品の悪いと言ったら
またわかったことになりますけど
まあこれは知識のレベルで言いますから
しょうがない言葉を使わなくてはできなくなっちゃいますからね
それでも私たちはダメになっちゃうんです
ですから 自分がすごく偉いんだと思ってもいけないし
同じやと思ってもいけないし
まあみんなより自分の立場が低いやと悔しいやと思うこともマーナであって
すべて自我から出てくるんです
私がいるんだぞと 正しい場合は何も思わない
そんなことは 食べる時は食べる
話す時は話す 何かゲームでもやった時は
誰かとね 相手が勝ったらあんた勝ったか
よかったんですよ それだけ
あんたあいつは上手で本当に悔しいって
そこは関係ないんですよ
悔しくて 今度はなんとかしてもう勝ってやるぞとかね
ゲームの相手が勝ったら
君が勝ったんですね よかったんですね
それで終わっちゃいますから
だから この心には傷つけてはいけないんで
そんなもんで自分の心を傷つくんですよ
慢があると このマーナっていうのは
この何か簡単に破れそうな何かの中に
何か鉄砲 鉄棒を一つ入れたような感じなんですよ
ちょっと触れちゃう すぐ破れてしまうと
薄いガラスの入れ物の中に
もう鉄の鉄棒 もう何か入れちゃうと
これ揺すっちゃうと壊れちゃうんですよ
だからマーナが入っちゃうと
自我であろうし 心がかなり傷つくんですね
成長がなくなっちゃうんです
人間に能力なくなっちゃうのはそういうことなんですよ
あの人々は本当によく勉強できていいなと思ったら
自分にできなくなっちゃうんです
だからかなり台無し状態になるんです
だから自己があると 自己ではなくて
自我があると エゴがあると
それ自体でみんな他人を測る
自分のことも測る お釈迦様はすごく困ったのは
他人の測ることをやめなさい
最初言ったでしょ 自分を測ることもやめなさいと
それはこちらでマーナになるんです
相手を測っているようなつもりで測っているのは自分なんです
あの人 私より随分できていて
優れていて羨ましい もっと自分を測っていますからね
この人はなんだ 私につまりはダメでしょ
こんなもんでと言っちゃう
高慢でしょ 自分を測っているんです
すごい危険な生き方なんです
で マーナがどれほどタチが悪いというと
その煩悩がこの完全に悟るまでなくならないんですよ
例えば悟りは段階説明していますよ
テキストでは段階目に阿羅漢果にならない限りは
もうマーナがうるそいてます
それぐらいタチが悪いんです
だから普通の世界ではみんなもうお互いに測り合って罵り合ってるんだというね
苦しみ合ってるんだということは
まあすごい当たり前のこと
それでもわかっておけば
もうできるだけ危険性を控えることはできます
悟ってなくすまで待ちましょうという甘い話は仏教は認めません
悟っても悟らなくたっても
それを置いておいて マーナはもうとにかく捨ててみなさいと
無理をして捨てることはできますからね
無理をしてでも捨てちゃうと
すごい幸せに 安らかに平安でいられるんです
世間の世界は仏教から言えばワンポイントだけですけど
またいろいろあることはあるんですが
そこら辺で終了したいと思います
ですから 世俗的な試験の場合は
前もったような生き方で生きていて
仏教の場合は心の場合
我々はみんなまあ相手を試験も測ろうとしているんです
人間である限りは 生命である限りは
それはマーナというすごい煩悩で汚れでありますね
で 心が傷つくんですので
人を測ることをやめましょうということで終了したいと思います
どうもありがとうございます